Speaker 1: All right, this is pretty interesting,
a former president, Donald Trump, has a new
spokesperson, his spokesperson had been that
guy, Jason Miller, but Miller stepped down
last week and the new spokesperson is a woman
named Liz Harington.
Liz Harington used to be the spokeswoman for
the Republican National Committee.
She's a real bomb thrower.
And Herrington's big qualification appears
to be that she supported a whole bunch of
lies about the 2020 election, which Trump
liked, including the lie that President Biden's
strong performance in some Democratic counties
clearly was a sign that there must have been
some kind of election fraud.
And one of the things that we've been talking
about is why might it be that even now so
many Republican elected officials are either
standing by Trump or at least not criticizing
Donald Trump?
And it seems pretty clear that the reason
is they see him, probably rightly so, as still
wielding lots of power, even for their own
possible reelections in 2022.
And they don't want to burn a bridge until
they know they're not going to need to drive
over that bridge any time soon.
So Donald Trump announces this new total suck
up brownnosing.
A spokeswoman says that Harington is a fighter,
apparently a fighter, for a completely bogus
conspiracy theories.
And Harington is just off to a blazing start.
She appeared on I don't even know what this
is, the real America's voice show.
Just the truth.
The truth is that the show is all lies.
And in this clip, Harrington says that the
January 6th Trump riots were a peaceful protest,
among many other lies.
You'll notice also that the interviewer is
former I guess it's former Trump lawyer or
was she Trump's lawyer?
You know, but we never really know.
Sometimes she was sometimes she wasn't.
Jenna Ellis.
She's the one that caught covid while traveling
around the country with Rudy Giuliani pushing
completely bogus voter fraud stuff.
So let's jump right in.
This is Trump's new spokeswoman, Liz Harington.
Speaker 3: Here we go.
Oh, absolutely.
And again, we've seen that there's such a
void mean you're not going to get it from
the Biden regime because everyone knows he's
not actually running things.
Speaker 1: So there's two things here that
are important.
The Biden regime is another phrase that they've
started using.
And this is, of course, part of their idea
that they want to push that the Biden administration
is some kind of dictatorial communist government
controls everything sort of administration.
So Biden regime is one thing we're hearing
from them.
The second piece is the idea that Biden isn't
really running the show and the idea.
So this is actually twofold.
There's a the big story and then the little
one.
The big story is it's the Biden dimentia story
that it's really Kamala Harris or someone
else who's running the administration.
But this happens to fit perfectly with anti-Semitic
stuff for Republicans as well.
And what I mean by that is the concept of
a behind the scenes Jewish puppeteer pulling
the strings of American government.
That's a classic anti-Semitic trope.
And so there's also sort of some symbolism
there as to why that's so appealing to many
on the right.
It's not overtly anti-Semitic, although there
were, you know, these things floating around
about, you know, a lot of Jews here, Ron Klain
and Janet Yellen.
And I don't know who that Blinken I don't
remember who else.
So it's all kind of part of this package and
it doesn't always have to be overtly signaling
Jews.
But the idea of like the real people pulling
the strings behind the scenes, it's implicitly
part of an anti-Semitic trope.
All right, let's continue.
Speaker 3: And it's so important at this time
in our country.
I mean, we have no equal justice under the
law right now.
The federal level,
Speaker 1: that's completely untrue, other
than a few mean that we have a two tiered
justice system where the rich and the powerful
are in a different sort of class of their
own.
What she means is certainly not true.
Speaker 3: I mean, just look at what they're
doing with the Justice Department.
You know, they didn't look into any of these
irregularities.
Oh, no, that's not the federal government's
role.
Right?
Speaker 1: It's literally not it's literally
not the role.
And these are the very same people who constantly
insist elections are run at the state level,
which is why we should be allowed to restrict
voting however we want.
We shouldn't have the federal government involved
in any way in how elections take place.
No Voting Rights Act, no nothing until all
of a sudden they say, well, we have six, six
or seven, you know, bogus election fraud claims.
Why isn't the federal government now getting
involved?
Speaker 3: The states are all.
And then all of a sudden, here comes a forensic
audit
Speaker 1: all through a forensic audit.
By the way, they come on
Speaker 3: to the Constitution and here comes
the corrupt Justice Department.
I mean, and we're talking about peaceful protests.
Speaker 1: It was not a peaceful protest if
if anything, was not a peaceful protest.
It was the January 6th riots, which now has
about 400 criminal defendants who had
Speaker 3: January six, they opened the doors
of the Capitol, which is supposed to be I
mean, we've both been there is not an easy
building to get into.
Speaker 1: Well, that is of course, not what
happened.
First of all, protesters physically breached
the door.
And secondly, for their own safety and to
avoid trampling, those officers had no choice
but to get the hell out of the way.
So every detail is being misstated here.
Speaker 3: You know, there's only if they
open the doors and people walk through, obviously,
we're not condoning you breaking property
or violence or you're not.
Some people just got just walks in and now
they're being kept and for misdemeanors and
some political jail.
And what is happening here?
What about the people that burned down St.
John's Church?
Speaker 1: St. John's Church, by the way,
was not burned down.
And that is yet another one of the distortions
and lies here.
So in all seriousness, they are going to continue
trying to rewrite the story of what happened
on January 6th.
We can't let them do it.
St. John's wasn't burned, burned down.
It was not a peaceful protest.
And consider how far things have gone that
Donald Trump's new spokeswoman, who is the
former Republican National Committee spokeswoman,
sounds more like Kuhnen than she sounds like
Mitt Romney.
You know, just a kind of milquetoast Republican
that we've come to know more more of this.
And by the way, they continue these conflicting
narratives of nothing really happened on January
6th.
But if it did, it wasn't Trump, it was people
pretending to be Trump is that also is a narrative
that continues.
So for now, as you see, you know, former RNC
spokeswoman is now Trump's spokeswoman.
The Republican Party seems, at least for now,
completely fine, staying completely associated
with Donald Trump.